have you ever watched one of those viral
videos where a baby hears their parents
for the first time after getting a
cochlear implant and thought Oh so
adorable
well what if I told you that the history
leading up to that moment isn't quite so
cute in videos like these doctors place
an electronic device near a deaf
person's ear that sends auditory signals
to the brain similar to hearing the Hope
Behind These implants is that they'll
allow the deaf person to participate
fully in the mainstream hearing world
but many deaf Advocates say that this
process is trying to fix something that
just isn't broken
instead they want us to recognize that
deaf people already have a rich
linguistic culture and community of sign
language users
with just as much validity as any other
language
and that signing needs less attempts at
correction and more of our attention I'm
Dr Erica brazovsky and this is other
words
[Music]
other words
I interviewed Roberta cardano President
of gallaudet University to discuss what
many of us misunderstand about sign
language
[Music]
foreign
I would say the biggest misperception is
the power and importance of American
Sign Language or sign language in
general just visual learning visual
language
I think too many people especially on
the healthcare Healthcare professionals
really completely misunderstand how
important visual language is for brain
development how important and equivalent
ASL is to English when we try to
describe what language is a lot of
people think about the shapes we make
with our mouths when we speak or the
sounds we hear or even the words we read
but gestures and facial expressions are
also parts of language every human being
wherever you are in the world already
has about 200 gestures that are innate
to them as human beings the brain
already knows how to produce these
gestures
but the problem is instead that we have
had gesturing scolded out of us I mean
think about it right if you think about
someone pointing right you're always
told not to point that it's not polite
right but imagine how efficient it is if
I point in One Direction you look to
where I pointed I don't have to say a
single word
sign languages are produced with hand
movements head movements and facial
expressions rather than sounds they have
all the same structural characteristics
that spoken languages do they have
complex vocabulary including Regional
variations in slang and grammatical
rules where things like the speed
direction and position of a sign can
change its meaning
and there's just as much Vibrance and
Variety in sign languages as spoken ones
there are more than 150 different sign
languages used around the world that are
distinct from each other and the spoken
languages in the same places
the only people in the world who are
still creating language not just words
but actual languages the only people who
are still creating languages in the
world are deaf people write spoken
languages have been static for the last
500 years as I understand it the last
couple hundred years there's no new
spoken languages being developed
anywhere but that's not true for sign
language
you know where there are deaf people
coming together they create new sign
languages to communicate I mean that's
incredible
sign language seems pretty cool right so
why don't more of us sign that's where
we get into some pretty painful history
until the early 1800s most deaf people
born in the U.S didn't have access to
education that could meet their needs
but in 1816 a collaboration between
French Educators and American Advocates
raised a bunch of money and established
a school for the deaf where students
could learn and communicate using signs
instead of speech
finally these students had access to
education but even more importantly to a
deaf Community where they could sign
with each other
the French sign language these teachers
brought started to combine the signs
that students made up at home or in
their own communities to create American
Sign Language or ASL
but not everybody liked this new model
of Education some academic Hot Shots
like Alexander Graham Bell yes that
Alexander Graham Bell argued that deaf
people including his own deaf mother and
wife should try to integrate into
mainstream speaking culture as best they
could
so in 1880 Bell and 164 other Educators
only one of them deaf
met at a conference to create
recommendations for Deaf education in
the U.S and Europe they believed that
sign language was a lesser imitation of
spoken language and that deaf kids
shouldn't be taught to sign in schools
instead they created a system called
oralism where deaf children were
expected to hear by lip reading and
speak by imitating the mouth shapes of
hearing people
that conference was catastrophic for the
deaf Community it ended most sign
language instruction in schools until
the 1960s that's almost a hundred years
where many deaf people had little to no
access to sign language education or the
ability to form communities with fellow
signers tell me
factor of those hang dogs if you haven't
been suited they've been treated out of
a good education
they've been treated out of a good
relationship with their own families if
you end up being treated out of so many
things because they will restricted only
to one method polishing another hunger
about that and to be hands with you
things to have I would have to be angry
and it was only in 2013 that there was
an apology issue to the deaf Community
for the Milan conference the Declaration
that spoke to Banning sign language back
in the 1880s
that apology to the deaf community that
came in 2013 was one that my mother was
still alive to see and my mother
suffered because of that decree during
that period of time and my mother said
you know I finally had lived to see this
apology that happened in her lifetime
and it meant a lot to her the problem is
you can't just treat someone like
they're not deaf and expect them to
blend in even the most skilled lip
readers report that they can only pick
up about a third of conversations so
that means that most deaf people denied
access to sign language are being denied
access to language period and that can
have some serious consequences for brain
development
the most important time to expose
someone to language for them to develop
fluency and for their brain to be
developed with you know the language to
be actually mapped to the language
mapping center of the brain is between
the ages of birth and five so we know
that any human being who wants to
acquire a language between that window
is the best opportunity for them to be
able to map that language to the right
area of the brain research has shown
that children who acquire language late
whether signed or spoken are less likely
to use the important language centers of
the brain instead they process language
in the visual or memory centers a less
efficient process that can still allow
for a large vocabulary but might inhibit
a natural grasp of the language's
grammar
every child who is deaf or hard of
hearing is at high risk of experiencing
language delay language deprivation
and it's not because the the child's
brain has limited capacity but rather
it's more about the fact that they've
not been able to have access to
information in a stress-free environment
where they can just learn freely
when I was you know younger I was the
only deaf person in the class and I had
to sit there and every minute of that
class I had to watch to make sure I
understood what was being said by the
instructor then I had to figure out what
was the meaning of the message that was
being shared in spoken language and then
I had to think about well what is it
that I just learned and then I have to
be ready to be called on by the teacher
at any point in time so I was doing four
separate functions every minute of every
single day all day long and that's
absolutely exhausting
even newer technology like hearing aids
or Cochlear implants don't work for all
or even most deaf people a majority of
cochlear implant recipients still cannot
pick up spoken language at a level
comparable to a hearing person and of
course we know there are many examples
of where people who are raised what we
call orally meaning that they have
hearing aids or Cochlear implants there
are many deaf and hard of hearing people
who are very successful going that route
and they thrive in their careers I mean
in no way am I criticizing that approach
and that lifestyle I think that's just
wonderful and again I'm not blaming the
doctors here because we also realize
that as well that in their doctor kit
that they bring to the table they're not
given anything that speaks to in a
prescription for ASL right that's not in
their tool kit right insurances play for
Cochlear implants they pay for hearing
aids but they sure don't pay for
language support
foreign what I'm trying to do is to get
people to realize that there's a false
choice that we're setting up here that
you have to choose one way of
communicating or the other both are
needed both are beneficial so why not do
both why not give the child everything
to that child's disposal to have to use
whatever they need and see whatever best
suits them and what they pick up
depriving a deaf child of sign language
in hopes to learn spoken language puts
them at a high risk for having
difficulty with any language later in
life but the reverse is also true
learning to sign from birth whether
alone or alongside spoken language has
some major cognitive benefits
if you saw our video on bilingualism
you'll remember that bilingual kids grow
up with cognitive advantages in memory
and attention the same holds true for
kids who learn both ASL and English
but because sign language uses
additional areas of the brain people who
speak and sign get a boost in Visual and
spatial processes too like giving
directions or remembering faces
[Music]
and that's true for people who are
hearing or deaf in fact research will
show that learning sign language for all
babies deaf and hearing will impact
their brain in such a way that it will
allow for further development of
abstract thinking pattern recognition is
enhanced there's loads of benefits that
visual language and visual learning
provide it allows your brain to thrive
in different ways that otherwise it
couldn't I mean it's just amazing what
can happen when you get exposed to a
spoken language in the visual language
and that's why I encourage having both
so even though for hundreds of years
Society thought that deaf people would
miss out on language and culture if they
learned to sign this whole time it's
non-signers who've been missing out on
an entire dimension of language and on a
Vibrant Community of deaf people who use
it
so what I recognize is is that we have
been so busy trying to fix deaf babies
or deaf hard of hearing babies by
putting Technologies on them and trying
to fix them so that they'll be hearing
and be able to access spoken language
that we've completely missed out on what
those deaf babies have to offer the
entire world a lifetime experience of
hearing loss and I think we've really
got it wrong the babies are our teachers
in this process they are teaching us how
to live with a beauty of a visual
language how to live in a world full of
visual images and visual communication
you know it's just a way of being that
is so beneficial to everyone if you
learn sign language and use sign
language
the more of us that join the signing
Community the more we can experience
broader and more complex ways of
thinking and more inclusive ways of
communicating with each other
before you go we're looking for your
feedback each year PBS digital Studios
conducts an audience survey it helps us
understand what you like and what you
want to see more of you also get to help
PBS pick new shows it only takes a few
minutes but your feedback is extremely
valuable to us there's a link in the
description thanks in advance